against Kerrigan then get the bomb down
there after this is gonna be very
difficult you just have like any time to
work with the bomb plus can take five
seconds long he's gonna go for it behind
the fountain caricatures gonna charge
him down is it miss Pratt a few pistol
shots Kennedy wanna kill around what's
up guys my name is Colin McNeill for the
score eSports and that was Kenny [ __ ]
s I could tell you he's one of the best
to ever play the game of Counter Strike
I could tell you he's in the discussion
the top offers ever but I probably don't
have to cuz if you know CS you know
Kenny and you know his play style and if
you don't well you're in for a treat
sit back hit the subscribe button and
get ready because this is the best of
Kenny s Kenny you know one versus three
and luminosity they are one round away
from match and mappoint here Kenny alias
little headshot he's got the double dip
sprays guess one more
there's no gut that way that he's gonna
do this he's gotta go find the shelf at
he being pressured up close he need
shots as he's looking for a playful win
squawk oh my god Kenny it's an
incredible kill against sixer I don't
even see the flicky hits that shot some
at all and it's another round for g2
planted still
stuck in the site finding more brilliant
applause oh my goodness yet the noscope
on the 3rd this guy's absolutely insane
hunting he might just got you good money
it's just okay dance is it just over the
bugs contrived top flash out doesn't get
these ideal that should not be possible
unreal from getting just knowing what
Kerrigan was gonna back to I'm making
the most out up oh my god Kenny s with
three insane kills okay so one of the
first things you need to know about
Kenny s is that he could be described as
a prodigy he started his professional
csgo career at 15 years old in
counter-strike source at the time he
played for one of the very best source
teams around very games Ken yes though
[Music]
picks up two headshots on who is he in
stock because the third one honest man
zine 216 Kenny s taken down ports again
so he's just winning the on bottles and
yes
nice jump econ dismiss with the AWP this
kid phenomenal upper Texas Phoenix
Charlie who's II scream drops RPK now in
favor of
excess the s takes out Smith's a 15 or
14 in favor of Texas no Phineas takes up
forks and smooth
[Music]
okay it has picked up two oxy and spins
what is this
against the Ken night speak on the
shocks as he peeked out at the tip of
the catwalk
[Music]
[Music]
now look in eSports terms all that
source stuff pretty much ancient history
these days he plays on French super team
g2 eSports and through op nerfs
roster changes and everything else he
remains the OP God we all know him to be
of a boiler very quickly in Kenny's in a
house anymore
three ninjas in his face very soon
oh that's is fast but that department -
very good job man but Lina fights to
Acadia stuff for the three versus one
this round should be done 20 seconds
remaining doubts of wars checkers is
good our first personal there to be
people how strong can he be the quickest
but that one does that first but not it
just catches the edge door in ten
seconds he spots another he's given
himself a chance he will absolutely go
on this but don't fool QB of all of this
these places don't put this on
immediately fast on that versus m4 and
Kenny why now play them honest
nice shot now that shows exactly where
he is but Kenny is very quick who is
going back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
might be the Cape again though only 11
left there's a knife it's on the metro
oh is it shoulder Kenny let's go they
call it a braggart little but it's
quickly dealt with for now it's just a
cleanup for g2 as they won't take that
lead back there he is
Kenny asked for the 4k to meet Koba
still to my shop that's the perfect
scenario Bobby can consistently do that
just go at it
baby's been doing great work doesn't
care people are playing this is but this
like you should be a K go for the triple
right now he's done immense damage
scholar cowboy how is he done this is a
smoke area never heard the city by that
indeed one is Kenny with a simply rude
peek into scope oh my goodness
Kenny s but look it's not just about the
OP a player like Kenny s can thrive on
just about any weapon just take a look
at this can I touch that now just get
back to wards I have to say big bad and
they are she fully committing now
they're running in for the teaser just
so Lord the pistol round here from
Everest working as Kenny s takes another
two into his bag about to see
call its dissolving as well flash
gorgeous nails it hits bronec wrapped
over to his last second shot for Kenny
you're ugly fast enough wrapped through
that second door put pressure on dueling
into candy
Chuck's still waiting no mall talk to
clear him out as well but it's afford
for us Kenny gets a kill early from the
wrong position he's gonna go for more
spots ahead there it is that's sick and
shocks with one more g2 on the verge of
turning this it's ridiculous isn't it
steel now oh my god heads are rolling
and it's clean yes so deadly down to two
now Kenny escape ex finding any is the
main plan here in Kenny wants it all
he's got four keeper and he's gonna push
on through but Kenny's found him and now
it's all on Guardian will you try and
hold y'all be kept the shut-ins way
picks is he gonna try and go huge here
Kenny and straight in his face
grunts another bomb some serious caches
if he Chinese get the first Hill makes
it a double looking for his side he gets
four in fact there's the ace what a way
to kick things off there for Kenny goes
massive in the Bissell than an ace in a
second as well
okay so he plays like a machine but you
have to understand that Kenny s is
success EDS and flows with his emotions
if he's feeling himself on a given day
get out of the server straight up if not
well
[Music]
there unfortunately but yeah and they
won't be proving a poise you can see the
emotional response after missing you
[Music]
frontways no he's pushed up lighter he's
been able to kind of stuff to execute
before they can even get started
he's be able to play back around like
that one and just catch the Messner
coming out so he's definitely kind of
very where he's taking it home and
that's a great work
the Kabul city side specifically because
it's just a matter of the fact that
[Music]
let's go yeah that is actually he's
embracing it who'd you rather face in
the finals we really want to face stuff
because they are witty cocky and we want
to show them that waiting at the event
doesn't mean anything else yes
whoo all right that's spicy I love it
god damn Kenny ass really is one of the
best now that's all we've got for you on
this week's episode of best of let me
know in the comments below who we should
cover next week and I'll see you then
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit the
subscribe button